bonjour aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de vous
parler de celui qui a fait trembler les
enfants pendant des centaines d'années
le loup et figurez-vous qu'en 2018 il ne
fait plus peur à personne même pas aux
trois petits cochons comme dans ce livre
- relou de philippe gilbert publié aux
éditions seuil jeunesse
les trois petits cochons se lance dans
une chasse au loup et commence pour cela
à une préparation militaire mais leur
instructeur est désespérée et le petit
lecteur comprend assez vite qu'ils ne
sont pas faits pour ça
alors les petits cochons temps de tendre
un piège au loup mais le loup n'est plus
féroce du tout et aimerait bien être
leur ami
c'est un album très plaisant acidulées
comme imprimer en sérigraphie
j'ai eu un vrai coup de coeur pour cet
album de philippe gilbert dont j'aime
beaucoup le travail et je vous conseille
le livre à partir de 5 ans vous allez
voir c'est bourré de rebondissements et
l'enfant ne sera pas jusqu'à la dernière
page si les cochons or ont la peau dure
figurez vous que le loup dans certains
histoire est même devenu végétarien
comme dans ce livre 1 ou dans le potager
de claire bouyer et quentin gréban paru
aux éditions méjanes il ya déjà quelques
années où le loup pour se nourrir s'est
lancé dans la culture d'un potager et il
y arrive plutôt bien c'est les bulls ont
tellement appétissant que les autres
animaux de la forêt et décide un jour
d'aller se servir
et là le loup se met vraiment en colère
il faut craindre le pire
finalement le loup décide de lancer une
bourse au cren
une décision assez incroyable mais
plutôt dans l'air du temps
le livre finalement a été écrit en plein
scandale de la vache folle mais on
retrouve à l'heure actuelle des
similitudes avec le courant vegan où les
potagers collectifs c'est un très joli
livre sur la coopération la rédemption
je vous le conseille les dessins sont
magnifiques et la philosophie qu'il
véhicule également le dernier livre dont
je voulais vous parler raconte
l'histoire d'un loup un peu simple
d'esprit
ça s'appelle le grand loup et la fée
rouge etc de véronique cauchy et rebecca
galera publié dans la petite maison
d'édition ces pages
alors cette fois le loup est plutôt
timide
on se moque généralement de lui et quand
il part dans la forêt pour amener des
provisions à son grand père et qui la
rencontre une petite fille avec un
chaperon rouge
il s'étonne que celle ci n'ait pas peur
de lui
c'est assez normal finalement car cette
petite fille est aveugle et elle ne
comprend pas pourquoi il faudrait avoir
peur très la rencontre de deux enfants
finalement de deux espèces différentes
et tous les deux porteurs d'un handicap
le livre est très jolie vous le voyez
les dessins sont proches de l'arbre
élite ou de là ils montent et parle d'un
trade de handicap très simplement comme
le ferait d'eux en plomb alors je vous
le conseille car ça permet d'aborder le
sujet avec des enfants dès 3
voilà j'espère que ces livres vous
permettront de voir que le loup est bien
n'est pas si méchant et je vous retrouve
une autre fois pour une autre chronique